when's the last time you've seen this
movie on the big screen um I mean since
it when it came out basically you know
cuz once you finish a movie like I don't
want to see it again because it's like I
I feel like I know it by heart uh so it
was pretty interesting like now few
years after seeing it again is there
anything you appreciate more now so many
so many years removed from the making of
the movie well I still appreciate the
run time like 80 minutes more movies
should be just a brief 80 minutes um no
but I mean it's it's a I mean once the
movie gets going it's pretty fun movie
but it's it's always like watching it's
like oh should have done that
differently should have done that and I
mean seeing the ending again now it's
kind of hilarious in that's like you
know mom shoots herself kids all
traumatized forever and like yeah
problem solved you know the
end all right you know I feel like
knowing some of the deleted scene ending
makes me feel better cuz to a point they
live happily ever after yeah I mean yeah
yeah she originally she came back again
but then people didn't like that because
then mom killed herself for nothing you
know so it's like makes sense yeah we're
going to get to that I wanted to go to
like broad horror movie uh talk to Star
CU it's Halloween we got to celebrate
horror movies I have two questions about
that first what is the very first movie
you remember scaring you keeping you up
at night I'm not sure I mean I The
Nightmare on Elm Street movies I watched
at a really young age I think that those
made an
impression yeah very appropriate movies
to be watching at a very young age in my
personal opinion so the next part of
that is what is the first horror movie
you remember watching that maybe scared
you but also made you appreciate the
movie Magic of the horror genre and
maybe made you want to give more
audiences out there that feeling through
your own films I think um The Nightmare
on Elm Street movies were definitely
part of that because they're so creative
as well like they're so imaginative with
the dreams and everything so they yeah
they were they were big for me they're
some of the absolute best in that
respect yeah so this movie went from
short to feature film the short went
online and it just it blew up it went
crazy everybody loved it yeah you get
whole lot of interest from Hollywood in
terms of people wanting to work with you
on making movies and I imagine that was
very exciting but what is the key to
pinpointing the right people to work
with because in my personal opinion you
found the perfect people to work with
yeah
um uh the first thing was to get an IMDb
Pro account to find out like who are
these people like what have they done
and like um no but it was just sort of a
gut feeling of the people who were like
really
into it like the producers and you
know yeah cuz I there's not much else to
go on like yeah do they seem like great
people to work with yeah you know feel
like the atomic monster team of makes me
very very happy yeah no I mean and James
Swan is is great I mean that's uh one of
The Producers on the movie Lawrence gray
he was saying you know like you need
there's only like at the time at least
there was only like two names that could
that could you know help you as a
producer and it was uh James Juan or G
Del Toro so and we got James Juan he you
know so that just means you have to work
with gon X yeah that's next upop
everyone knows we manifest things during
these q&as one other short question I
had for you when you made that did you
have any idea of what that version of
the entity's backstory was its reason
for being when we did the short yeah no
that that that was just for fun and even
when we did the movie
it was kind of it wasn't that figured
out I guess or things changed a little
bit throughout so it is a
little muddy and that she's not really a
ghost and she's like yeah she's a girl
with a skin condition but she also gets
into people's heads it's a pretty severe
skin condition I guess so it's like it's
it's not like super clear but it's like
yeah it's creepy stuff you know I'm
usually like a stickler for rules and
movie Bibles and all that stuff I I find
it to be very impressive that none of
that bothers me with this and I think
it's because the heart of the movie and
the characters and the relationships
between them are so strong yeah no yeah
and it's it's a pretty fun movie so it's
like you don't you know it doesn't break
just because of you know that backstory
going back to the beginning again so I
had heard that initially James didn't
think that the short was you know a good
thing to turn into a feature he didn't
know if it was possible but then you
wrote a treatment and that convinced him
that you did it like you could do it do
you remember what it was in that
treatment that convinced him that lights
out the short was worthy of a
featurelength film um I'm not sure um
but it was pretty close to what the
movie is like it had all the characters
and everything um um yeah I I think
maybe his concern was a lot of just like
yeah how do you stretch it out into a
full feature I mean that's always a
problem with a short where it's like oh
yeah it's a cool little contained idea
so you have to really come up with a lot
of stuff like I did even before the
story was completely clear I I made just
a list of like all these gags you could
do like yeah if you could turn on car
headlights you know to save yourself and
like oh if you shoot a gun maybe the
muscle flash will make them disappear
and like just all these things and then
as we worked out the story it's like
okay that beat could go here and that
could go there so it's just coming up
with as many ideas related to the
concept as possible is there anything on
that list that you were dying to use but
didn't get the chance to I don't
remember everything there was one thing
with like a car that was sinking down or
something so the light was like moving
so you had to like H try to stay in the
light as it was
moving um but I yeah I don't even
remember everything I wrote down there's
a lot of possibilities there so looking
back do you remember what it felt like
being on the set of this film for the
very first time because when you went
into this Not only was it your first
feature but you had never been on a film
set with like a big crew or anything
like that yeah I pretended like I had
that was a key sometimes that's all that
matters yeah uh no but it was I mean I
mean just coming there the first day and
seeing like the trailers and stuff and
like oh catering like it's like a it's a
real production you know like look at
all these people um um no but it was it
was pretty like terrifying and like a
lot of pressure put on myself as well
because it's like oh this is my one shot
you know like if this doesn't work out
no one's going to go like oh well you
want to make another movie you know um
so it's a a ton of pressure and I was
like pretty miserable but it was also I
mean it's it was exciting but it was it
was tough I I mean every movie is tough
for me I don't
know I I keep them for some reason but
they're yeah it's not always a good time
well we're grateful for it that you keep
powering through it I have a couple
follow-up questions to that because you
know there's there's a lot of pressure
here and I imagine it's scary to be on
your very first set with a with a
Hollywood crew around you but it's also
really important to to be a leader and
find that authoritative voice so you
could see your vision through to
fruition so do you maybe remember the
first time on set where I don't know you
kind of recognized the power in your own
voice and it gave you more confidence
going forward through the shoot well I
did kind of lose my
temper it was
um it was like you like I was working
with all these people who had done all
these big movies like big like X-Men and
things like that you know crew and here
I was was like I had less experience
than a PA on set you know so it's like
okay maybe I should just may you know
they know better than me but then was a
a camera thing where they were telling
me things that I knew was like no that's
not how it works I actually do know how
that works and we got into a little bit
of an argument but it it you know it
worked out and it felt like no I
actually do know these things I don't
know like the procedure of a typical
Hollywood film set but I know how movies
are made and how cameras work and like
how to tell a story so that gave me some
confidence I guess okay I'm going to
break that that down further like three
three-part question here okay I want I
want to know what's surprised you most
about the process of making a Hollywood
movie in every stage so like the
development stage on set but then also
when it came to finishing and releasing
the film I mean for production like
shooting it
um there was a lot of just like how long
everything takes and I I guess that goes
for the whole proc process that it was
just way too long and especially when
you're used to shooting like no budget
stuff at home where you can just like oh
we turn the camera around and look at
this way and on a movie set it's like oh
look at all this [__] we have to move
and like there's trucks outside and like
um and and it it was very stressful just
how long it takes to light a set because
it felt like oh they're lighting for
four to five minutes but then I have to
shoot it in like five minutes because we
have no time um things like that I guess
I imagine Lighting on a movie like this
is especially complicated just because
it's it's so important for it to be lit
enough but also extremely dark well yeah
and there was some guess some friction
with the the the DP I mean he's he's
he's he's a great guy but he was sort of
afraid of going too dark because it's
like if the studio sees you know all
that black they're going to go hey
people can't see the movie uh but it
turned out a little too bright in some
scenes that's one of the things that
makes me cringe like when Martin walks
out in the middle of the night and it's
like every light is on in the house um
little things like that okay I mean I
never notice any of that stuff no I mean
that's just me knowing all the things
but and and a weird thing with just like
post-production and things like that as
well was that if you just do like a
split screen or a fade you know like in
the in the short film to make the
creature appear and disappear in the
light is pretty much like a split screen
and just a fade and I was told like well
that's a VFX shot that's going to cost
money it's like what but that is so easy
to do so it's like how can it be more
limiting when you're doing a feature
than when you're doing a short when you
can just do it yourself okay here's a
here's a question about that having made
so many shorts and then a $5 million
horror movie and then also $200 million
plus superhero movies I'm curious your
take on this what is a film making
technique you used on lights out that
you wish more bigger budgeted
Productions would use where throwing
money at something having fancy tools
isn't the answer there's actually a
really simple way and effective way to
create that on screen I mean there's a
lot you can do with just cutting cuz
even um you know because of the whole oh
everything's a VFX shot you know like
when she wakes up in the middle of the
night and you have the red neon lights
going on and off I mean there's a lot of
there's a couple of shots where we see
her disappear but it's mostly just sort
of cutting back and forth and she's
there and she's not there but you still
get the impression that she disappears
and things like that so it's there's a
lot you can do with cuts and pretty
simple things and and we did that on
like Shazam as well like um do that
technique of like oh we need him to
super speed from there to there to there
so then you just have it there he
initiates a move and you do a whip pan
and and you have a cut in the middle
and then just do another whip pen when
he's already there and it's like super
simple but it works you know that's all
that matters is that it works yeah I
want to talk a little bit about the
design of Diana now actually also the
name why did you choose Diana the
originally it was going to be a demon
rather than a ghost that was yeah before
backstory changed and everything uh and
it was like the name the madeup name for
the demon was something like Deana
something that sounded kind of like
Diana so the explanation was that oh it
they thought her name was Diana but it
was actually this demonic name what
inspired the shift from demon to ghost I
think that was James Juan's idea of like
it should be someone Sophie knew in the
past rather than just a demon that came
into their lives it's a personal touch
want beefing up her character in the
whole situation and the process so now
what about the design of Diana we do see
a similar look in the short but then
there are some noticeable upgrades here
yeah oh the the big thing was that I
wanted her to be naked and that was a a
big deal everyone was like she got to
have some wear clothes but then it's
like well then you have to decide on
what she was going to wear and then like
did she wear it when she died or like
what happened it felt more like and to
me it's like it's more terrifying being
chased by someone who's naked than
someone who's fully clothed you know
like cuz you know that person's crazy
you
know so just felt more scary but we
actually did just to sort of satisfy
everyone asking for it we did like a
camera test with like a dress on it's
just like yeah no I mean I can't confirm
that's true from experience but it
certainly feels like an accurate
assessment of that but it was the whole
thing of like well you know what do you
do about nipples and things like that
but it's like oh it's just burned skin
you know like fair question fair
question all right let's talk a little
bit about your cast now because I mean
another another thing with this being
your first feature is that you had
really only directed L before and then
all of a sudden you have this big
Ensemble here so can you maybe tell us
something about your leads in this movie
that taught you something about what it
meant to be an actor's director that you
still find yourself using today well it
was a weird movie and that it came
together really fast and so we started
shooting it before the the parents had
even been cast like Maria Bell hadn't
been cast when we were started shooting
the movie so when when we have that
opening uh in Martin's room and you see
like the family photos those were all
just green screen frames cuz we were
like we don't know who's going to play
these actors and then we had to like
comp all that in afterwards so I didn't
get to like rehearse or do anything like
that like Maria Bell I met on set for
the first time like 5 minutes before her
shoot um but it was great just working
with such professional actors because
that made it work because they just came
on set and did it and it was like it was
so cool just sitting there by the
monitor watching like oh it's like a
real movie you know like they are yeah
I've seen these people on TV you know
you really lucked out with this cast you
got a special group here yeah um broad
question about the entire production
going into filming is there a particular
particular set piece that you thought
was going to be the most difficult to
pull off and then in the end was that
really the toughest of the bunch or did
another one wind up catching you by
surprise in that respect yeah I mean the
the sort of the basement was sort of
tricky just with the UV light and how
to do everything especially so the
reveal of Diana like uh how can we do
that in down there but uh but it turned
out not too far of from what I had in
mind actually so I mean it's just
working with great people who know what
they're doing then can sort of realize
your vision I guess I want to move into
post-production but before I do that
just one big burning question I've
always had does Sophie really like
elephants you mean she's watching that
on TV that was you know it's rights
clearance and things it was I I don't
know why we had to have something on TV
and they just had some sort of elephant
show show and it's like okay and then
even even the movie they watched was
like well you have to pick a Warner
Brothers movie from before 1960 because
after 1960 I know some sort of different
copyright thing or whatever so it's like
so that's why they're watching Auntie
MIM and it's like you know Martin's
favorite
movie yeah again still works um so I had
heard somewhere that you weren't a big
fan of the first assembly of this movie
at that point what was bothering you
about the assembly and then do you
remember the first edit that you made
that finally made you think like we've
got something special here yeah it's
always a shock sort of when you watch
the first cut of any movie but I didn't
know that then well I actually I had
been told by The Producers like yeah you
know when Ben Affleck first saw the
first cut of Argo he was like oh my
career's over and then he won an Oscar
so it's was like oh okay yeah I'll keep
that in mind and then you watch it it's
like this is [__] awful because the
thing was like when you were on set and
you're like watching through the Monitor
and listening to the things like things
can look kind of cheap but you're like
yeah but then in post it's some kind of
movie filter they put on there and
everything will be great and then you
watch the movie it's like oh no there is
no such filter um no
so it's just a matter of cutting out as
much you can cuz cutting out everything
you hate until there's just like oh you
can't cut anymore that's sort of the the
strategy for for every movie um no but
but I mean you I've you get a little bit
more used to it
like you know you you know that once you
get better sound in there once you get
the proper score in there and there is
color correction everything that that
comes after but but when you do test
screenings you don't have any of that so
that that's pretty terrifying yeah I
have questions about test screenings
that process seem seems like horrific to
me or high pressure I should say can you
tell us about the test screening process
and maybe give us an example of a note
you got applied and it made the movie
better but then also maybe a note where
you knew you had to trust your gut and
that's what would serve the movie best
yeah I mean the interesting thing was
that when we did our first test
screening I mean you keep it pretty
small and it's like very you just play
the movie straight from the Avid you
know without anything
fancy and the first test screening we
did it felt great watching the movie
because everyone's like the audience was
so into it and they were making noise I
like oh this is great and then the
scores came back and they were like me
so I was like what happened like you
could tell that people liked it and then
we read all the cards and people hated
the ending because it was that longer
ending when she came back again um and
they had to defeat her again uh so what
we did was we just ended the movie right
where we ended here just just Fade to
Black rather than do the other ending
and did another test screening and the
scores went through the roof like it was
tested great so I mean that certainly
taught me that endings are very
important like you can have all this
Goodwill just ruined by a bad ending um
and and I
think yeah like sort of trusting myself
with notes I
think in this movie I didn't really do
that I was like anything the audience
said was like okay because what one of
the thing they did want was more
backstory it's like okay we'll do more
backstory and put it in there um but
then reading reviews and things when the
movie came out people like too much
backstory it's not scary like we know
too much like God damn it they trick me
damn test audiences not to turn this
into a review again but I'll agree to
disagree on that point um speaking of
the end of this movie I remember way
back when there was talks of a lights
out sequel I'm going to assume that it's
not going to happen anymore so at this
point are you able to reveal anything
about what you might have had planned
for uh the series next yeah I mean I
don't know cuz it's been so long now we
did have a draft uh at one point
but I mean in that draft Martin was
still young and he's not young anymore
he's like a man now you know um no but
it was it's
um it was introducing sort of she was
sort of attacking a new family but then
this cast got involved to sort of help
out with that um because I mean you kind
of have to do that or because the fun
thing with a horror movie is when the
discovery you know when the ha ating
starts and you don't know what's going
on so if you have if she just comes back
to this cast like well yeah we know who
Diana is we've done dealt with her
before you know so if you have a
different family at first that then they
can go through all that but then you can
have this cast come in and sort of you
know be the experts to to help defeat
that still sounds possible you just make
you make he grew up yeah I mean sure
yeah again I manifest I like to will
things into existence
would you ever want to adapt any of your
other short films into a future we're
working on that actually that's um on
the way I'm not can't say which
one but it's actually yeah to okay I'll
take that tease I've watched I've
watched quite a few of them I'll take
really anyone that's coming to mind
right now um I mean given that does that
mean you are you're returning to the
horror genre next and can we keep you
there please yeah yeah no I'm definitely
doing horror next I'm very eager to to
get back to that because it feels like I
have so much more to to do I have so
much more Horror in me you know I was
just getting started with anabo creation
then I took a superhero detour yeah well
is there any like even though they're
two completely different genres is there
any like new tool in your directing tool
kit that you know you can credit to the
Shazam movies that you're eager to apply
to a movie Next I mean the big thing
with Shazam movies is that you work with
a lot of visual effects but I kind of
I'm really tired of that right now so uh
I don't know what would apply more than
just an accumulation of film making
knowledge like with every movie you make
you just learn a lot of things you just
more Tools in your toolbox you know
before I toss it to the audience one
thing I love asking because again this
is your first Fe feature and I think
it's a a really special thing in this
industry when people get behind a new
voice and help get their first film off
the ground so it's a kind of pay it
forward in a sense is there any emerging
voice in the horror genre that really
excites you and you want to make sure
people know their name um yeah I mean
there's a lot of cool ones I mean I
Parker Finn who just did the smile movie
you know I I think he's and I mean Zach
craer who's barbar that was awesome I
mean there's a lot of cool guys out
there right now and uh you know talk to
me was great those Australian I think
they are those guys there's a lot of
great horror I mean horror is the sort
of the the Dependable genre for the for
the movie business because they're like
almost all always making money you know
they're so cheap to make and they make a
lot of money and everything you just
dropped is like high quality hard and I
feel like we've been getting an
especially large amount of those kinds
of films in recent years yeah and I'm
very grateful for it all right I'm going
to toss it to the audience now we're
going to get to as many questions as
possible you're the firstand I so you
can go first uh and and David thanks for
being here um one of the the really
impressive things about lights out is
narratively speaking a lot of it has to
be set in the dark which means it's hard
for audiences sometimes to potentially
see things but you could actually see
things very clearly here versus let's
say episodes of Game of Thrones right
how did you accomplish that like from
cinematography level just from a
directoral level like how do you set
those scenes in the dark but allow
people to see what's going on this was
about the filming things in the dark and
like how do you like not doing the Game
of Thrones things where you can't see
anything but but and so keeping it dark
but seeing things I mean it's it's all
about contrast uh to to you know that's
I think that's the problem with a lot of
shows and movies that there's no
contrast in there that that makes it so
you can make things seem much darker
than they are if you have those bits of
light in there I mean and and it was for
this movie it was tricky you know we had
to do a lot of work in the DI often to
bring things down because they were too
bright um but I I do like to have big
areas of like darkness in the frame I
think that's ideal where you can't see
what's hiding in there but you have
enough lights on the things you do want
to see first I just want to say I'm a
big fan of your work and the content
that you release on your YouTube form I
think it's very inspiring to aspiring
filmmakers so I want to thank you for
that thank
[Applause]
you and one thing that I always walk
away from your films with is just how
well you develop your characters one of
the reasons why Shazam is one of my
favorite DC films is just how swept up I
get in Billy's story and the Shazam
family story and their lovable Dynamics
together so my question for you is is
just where in your creative process does
do characters come in exactly do when
you're choosing a project or when you
develop project are you thinking about
how you can really flesh out the
characters and where you can kind of
just Center It Center the story around
the characters how does that play in
your developing yeah when it comes to to
characters um in the movies I mean to to
me I don't I haven't written any of the
features um so that's uh that I've
directed so I mean so much of that is
the writers working with good writers um
and I mean even with
I I try
to almost like take a step back when it
comes to working with a lot of actors
and things where it's like I I want to
see what they bring to it like like you
you hire the right uh people that are
close to the characters that they play
or or have are able to to to bring that
out easily because I mean it makes your
job as a director so much easier if the
actors are almost like doing it
themselves because there's so much
technical stuff and other things to to
focus on um but yeah I mean to me
the the characters is
almost sometimes more important than
story you know um but I I credit the
writers and the actors for that a lot to
expand on what you're were saying with
the writer I was curious to know more
about your process in terms of working
with a treatment instead of like a
finish scrip I mean a lot of media
presents it that directors have to be
full R tours that present the studio
with a finished script in a bow and I
just wonder what it was like utilizing a
treatment as your um storytelling Outlet
as opposed to yeah I mean it's it's
always a back and forth even you know
whether it starts with a treatment or
whatever with the studio as well um cuz
I mean you you you do want to make sure
that you're all aiming to make the same
movie or you're going to have a a bad
time um but yeah now it's it's always
been
back and forth process of of like hey
how about this and you know they come
with ideas and I come with ideas and um
you sort of
find the story I guess uh what advice
would you give to filmers because I know
with like YouTube channels making a
whole lot of money now at these time and
age do you kind of suggest them going
towards Hollywood or kind of stick into
their own independent YouTube
channel um well I mean most of my advice
is just about making stuff because that
that's the most important thing you know
where and then you'll see where it ends
up because I think a lot of people are
too focused on like oh do I have the
right camera or like I don't have the
right camera so I can't create something
it's like no you have to like create
things as much as you can because you
will learn with everything and and
you'll um just increase your chances of
of finding an audience but whe you know
what you're asking about whether doing
things for YouTube or for for like
Hollywood I don't know I mean I'm an old
school sort of movie guy but uh I mean a
lot of interesting things do happen on
on YouTube I mean YouTube is the
streaming
service that I use the most you know I I
happily pay for premium because I get I
use it more than Netflix and all of
those others um but yeah you know I'm
old school guy who likes films I think
it would be sad if it turns too much to
just like YouTube and things like that
but it's a great platform to to just
create all kinds of things that doesn't
have that don't have to fit into any uh
what do you say call it
like any particular box like a movie box
or it can be be anything I'll just
further emphasize your YouTube channel
is exceptional if you want to watch some
of his shorts but also get a pretty
significant amount of behind the scenes
information and really useful film
making 101 tips Pony Smasher on you to
because it is something you should be a
professor one day I'm dead serious I'm a
YouTube Professor the way that you
explain things I find it very easy to
process and I think there's a lot of
young filmmakers out there that would
benefit from it all right I'm going to
go up to the top right in the middle you
were one of the first hands I saw oh you
already worked in like The Conjuring
universe but if you
what other like horor I would you dip
your toes into you have a
chance um I mean sometimes I'm I'm like
would a Nightmare on Elm Street movie
work but but it's like what do you you
don't want to reboot it and it's like I
don't know um but I mean that's
something I I've have thought of like
could you do something there maybe I we
need to redeem that franchise yeah I
feel like we can't we can't end it with
the last one
yeah um no but otherwise it's like no I
most franch franchises I'm just I just
want to enjoy you know and just not have
them ruined do you have a favorite uh
you know iconic slasher franchise or any
horror franchise for that matter I mean
the Alien movies were up there but uh
they're horror
um yeah I've never been huge on slashers
to be honest um my
heart no I mean there are some good ones
out there
but they sometimes they feel more syy
than some of the other genres in my
opinion but I mean if it's done good
it's it's great but you know the answer
was on my shoes the entire time if you
can see it what is that custom scream
sneakers everyone go buy them from
Andrew L yeah I mean scream is fantastic
it's fantastic you know so but it's yeah
that was the right response to that yeah
all right we had more up top there right
there
first you got it I wanted to Second all
the your YouTube channel is fantastic
thank you my version of you know
Everyone likes to say the whole you know
oh be [__] broke his toe I always like
to point out in the back of Shazam I'm
like those are crew
members yeah um but uh I want to ask
kind of a silly question I in the open
scene of this movie lights out uh I
maybe I'm crazy you can tell me if I'm
crazy but I swear is that a bobble head
of the original creature design from
theal Shore and if so do you still have
it and if not where is it no it is it
was done by our production designer
Jennifer Spence and it's in our uh our
bookshelf at home yeah no that I I I
love that little thing first off want to
say extremely excited for the Smasher
Cinematic
Universe I was curious uh from all of
the work you work with on uh Shazam
Shazam 2 or Shazam adjacent uh is there
any actor uh or actress that you would
love to just kind of see in a horror
movie uh and it just makes some
Beau um Helen
Maran I mean she's done horror uh she
did that Winchester movie yeah no but I
mean I I really can't see sary Levi in a
horr I'm sure he could do it but I
having a hard time seeing it
um yeah no but I mean I I most actors I
just want to keep working with you know
and and I I try you know like with Grace
who's in the Shazam she was in annabal
creation first you know she's great um
so yeah know I want to work more with
with everyone I'll just use that as an
excuse to say Annabelle creation is
excellent everyone go watch Annabelle
creation if you haven't all right the
yeah you and then you um so I everyone
has already been saying you know big
inspiration um I'm an aspiring director
and so is my friend and I noticed that
nobody really talks about this this
issue that I've had and it's with um the
technicality of film making like when
you get a new camera you look at the
settings and he just I I don't want to
learn that um was there any way that it
made it easier to learn that you know
when I hear numbers and letters together
I'm like I don't what does that even
mean um was there anything to help you
with that uh I mean I've always been a
nerd so I I I do want to learn that uh I
that's sort of my special interest of
like oh yeah how does it work and how
does this uh and just doing trial and
error and things but I
mean as a director you don't
really have to know that those kinds of
things you know like on a certainly not
on on features like I don't touch the
camera myself you know I just tell other
people what I want um but yeah when it
comes to like yeah learning cameras and
things to me I I do enjoy that but um so
I yeah I'm not sure what advice to give
there well I'll just pay it back up
everyone say huge fan the mom super
jealous that here
well thank you all your shorts and
behind the scenes to um I just wanted to
ask about because it's been interesting
that especially now after all the fils
feature films you made you made were
kind of funneled into each film it
lights out of course being a feature but
then because of your relationships there
then getting to do Annabelle and then
Shazam and Shazam 2 and now
you can do a lot more and have a lot
more options and I read a little bit
about kind of like some of your future
projects and stuff you you a lot of
things going on and I'm wondering how
many projects to work on um especially
now uh after you know having all these
opportunities uh at a time and is one of
them uh flipping you off for four hours
yeah uh so how many projects you I work
on at a time um that's is one of the
things I
don't like about Hollywood that you
you're because because I like to focus
on like one thing like you make this
movie and then you figure and then you
go on to something new and you just
focus on that but here you kind of have
to have all these projects going at once
because one you know this project might
not happen for whatever reason and or
this might get delayed so you have to
have a bunch of balls in the air and
then like the one that goes first that's
what you go with
but it's really hard for me to keep my
focus on several things at once I really
don't like that um right now it it seems
that I have my next movie and I it seems
like this one is happening uh I'm I'm
very excited about that but even so I
there's still all these projects
happening at the same time and you have
to
like it's just that that sort of um
switching your your brains CU like
you're all in on this movie and then
it's like oh we have to have a meeting
or talk about script about this movie
and then you have to like try to forget
that and my brain doesn't really work
like that so that's but hey I'm working
on a lot of projects at the same time
that's pretty fortunate so Pony Smasher
Cinematic Universe yeah whoever said
that I like it let's keep saying it
because it's going to happen
congratulations on lights out and
everything you've accomplished and thank
you so so much for being here for this
screening series it meant the world to
me to include this movie and you in it
thank you so much thank you for having
me thank you guys so much for being here
tonight have a good night
[Applause]
everyone